[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to yesterday has just hit cinemas
worldwide and the movie has a lot to
unpack from its plot and ending Danny
Boyle apparently walked out James Bond
to make this movie and throughout this
video I'll be breaking down whether I
think it was worth it and what the
endings of the film means this is full
spoilers ahead so if you don't want to
know what happens and haven't seen the
movie yet
then I highly suggest that he turn off
now without the way I just want to give
a huge thank you for clicking this video
I hope you enjoy it now sit back relax
and let's get into my breakdown of
yesterday yesterday follows Jack Malick
a struggling musician who decides to
give it all up after he realizes that
his career's going nowhere like this
channel now that Game of Thrones has
ended anyway after there's a worldwide
blackout and Jack is involved in a
head-on collision with a bus he finds
himself in an alternate universe where
the Beatles never existed as anyone
right
ever heard of the mandolin effect it's
when a group of people incorrectly
remember something and many think that
it shows that the multiverse actually
exists like my classic examples are the
bird steamed bears and dark Vador saying
I'm not the father yeah honestly it's a
real look it up it's the mandolin effect
how many of you were triggered right now
yeah it's the Mandela effect it's the
but I know what it is stop right in your
comment anyway there's a number of
theories on the blackout ranging from
solar flares to extraterrestrials and
even an act of God but whatever the case
the Beatles never existed and therefore
Oasis couldn't steal all of their songs
anyway Jack on the other hand is willing
to take all of their work and quickly he
rises to the forefront of the music
world being labeled as the best musician
of all time
by Ed Sheeran who makes his performance
in Game of Thrones Locke oscar-worthy
just kiddin ed will love you
however as Jack ascends into
superstardom he quickly catches the eyes
of two other people who like he does
remembers the
and slowly they began to menacingly show
up to geeks which worries Jack that he
may be exposed to make matters worse his
longtime friend led professors her love
to him but states that in order to be
with her Jack would have to give up his
dreams and remain in England basically
issues what yoko ono should have done
because this makes jack run for the
hills and he continues his rise of
stardom until after ellie contacts him
he decides to do a gig at the Pierre
hotel which he used to frequent after
the gig the two characters that were
aware of who was really behind the songs
confront Jack but rather than being mad
about it they stayed there happy that
someone is out singing the songs that
they love for the world they hand him
over a piece of paper that just so
happens to have John Lennon's address on
it
Jack goes to visit John and finds him
living a solitary life by the beach in
this small cottage that is a far cry
from the superstardom that the real
Lennon had Jack asks if he feels like
he's been successful to which John
replies he's happy so he is this is of
course a callback to the famous quote in
which John said that at school when he
was asked what he wanted to be when he
was older and he said happy the teacher
scoffed and said he didn't understand
the question and John apparently replied
you don't understand life John clearly
has led a better life than all of the
fame and fortune would have led him to
as had he never graced the stage with
Paul Ringo and George then he would have
never been murdered by Mark David
Chapman several years later the fact
that Lennon is alive and happy having
lived a full life without his music ever
being popular cements for Jack that fame
and fortune or not everything and it's
more important to be happy than to be
what's deemed successful by society and
be kinda interested to see what Lennon's
estate thing of this betrayal as it's
pretty much saying that he almost wasted
his life chasing the wrong things and
would have been better in a place if you
just kept himself to his self but either
way Jack realizes the importance of the
Beatles and in a final concert he
announces the truth about the songs and
releases them free for the world he
settles down with Ali choosing her to
have a family with and he returns to
teaching to still sing his songs at
school whilst he never becomes wealthy
and wildly famous
becomes rich in other ways that mean
more than millions of fans and top 10
trending ending explained videos on
YouTube please like share and subscribe
anyway it's quite a nice message to take
from the piece and one that I wasn't
really expecting especially with the
John Lennon cameo I think the film works
excellently at perhaps showing that Fame
is in all it's cracked up to be and it
often comes more problems than happiness
when you're trying to please everyone in
the film the performances especially
Ellie really showcase that perhaps as
simple fulfilling life is better than an
overt shallow one and it's a message
that I think is desperately needed in
our social media society where everyone
is trying to be the next big thing on
Instagram overall I had a lot of fun
with the film and whilst it does drag in
some parts it works brilliantly at a
reminder of just how good the Beatles
music was unlike Bohemian Rhapsody and
Rocket Man this still manages to pay the
sentimental look at the lives of the
Beatles without the need for the piece
to be centred around them which is not
an easy task overall I had a lot of fun
with yesterday and it gets a 7 out of 10
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film and what you took from the
Lennon cameo so comment below and let me
know and if you enjoy this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of last week's big
release Toy Story which would be linked
at the end this is the channel for
people who were mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]